as a Buddhist monk the another location
independent paths they talking with some
noble Lords at that time also i
mentioned as a Buddhist monk I always
look a different angle or the problem
mainly true sorrow what is our
motivation and what's the what kind of
emotion i believe the every action
whether positive or constructive or
destructive finally is much depend on
motivation so for example violence and
non-violence ultimately I think make
distinction mainly on day on the basis
of motivation with compassionate
motivation the action appears more
artful or even harsh word but
essentially non-violence out of the
motivation want to cheat want to exploit
on other want to take advantage
advantage they use nice word press some
smile that not James mine but some other
few smile hmm then these looks
non-violence nonviolent action but
because of the motivation and aim try to
harm another try to hurt try to use
positive they take advantage so
essentially violence so motivation is
the essential very important
you